so we do have our first diagnosed case
of Ebola in the United States there is
someone in a hospital in Dallas he was
in Liberia came back from Liberia on
September 19th developed symptoms a
couple days later and then as of this
morning it now sounds like there might
be a second person I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that but might be
okay everyone's freaking out already
when this Ebola things started I
actually you were on the show that day
and you gave us a good cleanup of it so
as our as our resident science person
here all right is the first diagnosed
one Obama said it probably wasn't going
to happen the president supposed to be
in charge of absolutely everything at
all times how freaked out should we be
right now not at all no we shouldn't be
freaked out at all like we don't live in
West Africa I think the people of West
Africa should be very nervous and they
should be very careful and there are a
lot of things that are happening right
now in West Africa to try to contain the
the outbreak of this infection and
unfortunately they're not working to the
extent that we would like them to be
working because of all sorts of
pressures that we can get into but in
the United States the level of care that
we offer is absolutely superior every
single Hospital is equipped with
isolation wards doctors know how to
isolate individuals quarantine
individuals to prevent further
contamination and I think that one thing
that we have to remember about Ebola is
that we need to keep kind of these two
words separate in our heads which is how
contagious is the disease and how
infectious is the disease it's not a
very contagious disease but it is highly
infectious which means if you come in
contact with it it's likely that you
will contract the virus but it's not
very likely that people come in contact
with it because you can only get it
through bodily fluid exchange ok so you
calm down my rather hysterical intro
stop watching contagion the thing in
contagion was airborne right which is
why it spread so quickly Ebola is not
airborne ok so
uh the media you are in the media
Lysette how do we present this without
going crazy cuz they're it because
that's the thing like I was watching all
the cable news channels flipping through
mall last night and there is this like
they have to sort of stairs yes there's
a necessary because we have one guy and
again not airborne but I do want to get
back to something about that but how
should the media handle this yeah I mean
I think it's a question of how should
the media it's not just how should the
media handle it but how is it handling
it and why so as you alluded to a lot of
times the media needs to sensationalized
stories in order to get clicks right if
you say something like oh there's some
disease out there it's killed a couple
people no one's gonna click on that so
you in some sense the reason why people
read articles is because of fear because
they have an emotional reaction to it so
thumbnail on this video we're gonna put
a zombie shooting blood addict ma you
know you go but it's really unfair and
then the other thing too that I think
the u.s. is being criticized of as being
I'm slightly on you know American
centric right we're focusing on
Americans and when Americans are
afflicted with the disease or can
contract the virus we were up in arms
right so we didn't do much about
unfortunate we didn't do much about the
Ebola outbreak in West Africa until some
are American US aid workers that were
there contracted the disease right and
that's when everybody kind of went up
and I was like oh my gosh like American
people and all of a sudden the CDC came
up with like oh we have an experimental
vaccine and they've been cured well
you're right now I have to interject
America was doing a lot in West Africa
when we first heard of interest in terms
of the media however it was a
collaborative didn't care and that's a
problem and the media wasn't covered it
covering it appropriately I don't think
but basically we didn't hear about it
until those people got sure but the CDC
was working very hard and our our
members of the World Health Organization
there was a lot of American research
those happening there's a lot of aid
that was going over there it just wasn't
that big of a story yeah
so okay so we we know it's not airborne
so how did the doctors and the aid
workers there you would think like I
picture again this is cuz i'm watching
contagion and i'm watching what was the
other one with the was that other one
contagion hot zone oh you think out
right right like they got all those
things on and yet so if it's not
everyone how did doctors who are taking
care of these people it seems like it's
pretty hard to contract actually it's
not hard to contract it's it's okay it's
good clean it up it's very infectious
which means that if you come into
contact with somebody who's exhibiting
symptoms it's very likely that you're
going to contract the disease because it
is contracted via bodily fluids and
because individuals who are symptomatic
are often vomiting they have diarrhea
and they may believe that's actually a
symptom that's it is a hemorrhagic fever
and on autopsy you do see a lot of
hemorrhaging within the body or some
hemorrhaging I think it's been overblown
the idea that people are bleeding from
every orbit that's just not what Ebola
patients look like yeah but if
somebody's coughing they're getting
virus all over their hands all over
their arms if an aid worker is you know
touches their skin and then brushes
their hands against their their eyes or
something that's how it's getting into
their bloodstream so it is very easy to
contract it if you're in direct contact
with somebody who's symptomatic okay so
unfortunately too many of the facilities
are in hospitals in West Africa are
being overwhelmed they simply cannot
handle the number of cases so what's
happening is that some patients are
vomiting on the floor you know they've
been accounts to where they're simply
just not being taken care of so there's
an issue of control here as well and
being able to take care of the people
that have the disease and this is also a
zoonotic disease this is something that
we have to keep in mind too which means
that like there's all these different
terms when we talk about epidemiology
like the index case here in America this
new person in Dallas is an index case
meaning that they contracted the disease
and potentially spread it while in
America whereas those two aid workers
that were brought over there weren't
index cases they were already sick they
were brought over for treatment and they
were in isolation the whole time but
when we talk about the way that the
disease is being contracted in West
Africa there is person-to-person
infection but it's also a zoonotic
disease which means that people get it
directly from infected chimpanzees and
gorillas so it's a the way that Ebola
got its hooks in in what
Africa is because people were eating
bush meat and that continues to happen
there's been a lot of educational
efforts but we're going to continue to
see new cases occurring also in West
Africa source cases we don't see that
here in United States okay so I'm glad
you're making that distinction so
clearly we have better health practices
here it's safer here etc etc but what
can we do in terms of like this guy was
in Liberia and then got on a plane so
again not to promote hysteria but should
we be doing something a little bit
differently shouldn't he had maybe been
quarantined for a couple days if you're
coming from this country like that the
border part of this is the part that
seems odd yeah I mean yes should we be
doing more perhaps but logistically I
think it's really difficult to
quarantine people because the symptoms
can take up to 21 days to manifest so
what are you gonna do what's it like
what's finally came back exactly and
they are screening people for fever
before they come onto the plane now I
guess the on the flip side are on the
deposit on a positive side um people are
not contagious until they manifest
symptoms so for the four days in which
he was you know um presenting these
symptoms then perhaps people could have
contracted the disease but when he got
on the plane when he got off the plane
no one there was at risk of contracting
the virus know which is a funny to see
it spread across the country okay you
know also i'm also watching strain right
now which probably doesn't help my glad
i have two more things before you you
wrap the segment up the one thing is
that there's a really great book it's
called spillover by david quammen and
it's a really good answer to Richard
Preston's the hot zone which kind of
over blows the symptoms of Ebola and the
second thing is everybody should go on
their apple tv's and download the PBS
app and watch the recent episode of
frontline where a reporter actually goes
into the field in Sierra Leone and gets
a first-hand look of one of the doctors
without borders hospitals there you can
see how overwhelm they are you can see
you know the dire straits that they're
in exactly what they're dealing with in
West Africa but you'll also see it'll
humanize it a little bit for you you'll
see patients with Ebola you'll see that
they're not bleeding out of every
orifice they're real people they look
like they have the flu they're very sick
but it might take some of the
fear away as well yeah ok so then last
question on this just clean up the one
other thing that I think everyone is
sort of thinking but not asking which is
what causes something like this to jump
from the way it is now to airborne
because that's the part where everyone
will freak so can you just clean that up
and then I think we did something pretty
sane indecent here they don't they don't
know where you go passagens work the way
the pathogens work there's no reason to
believe that the transmission the way
that this disease is transmitted will
change this is a very ancient disease we
see many cases of it historically from
as i said before species to species so
somebody eats a chimpanzee that was
infected they get infected and then they
can then transmit it to people who are
close to them there's absolutely no
reason to believe that it'll ever be
airborne that that will ever be a risk